nichée sur une roche de granit saint
benoît du sault est une cité médiévale
de 600 âmes est pas loin du double de
touristes en été elle séduit par son
authenticité ses ruelles pentues ses
porches et ses vieilles pierres un joli
terrain de jeu pour les amateurs de
dessins et de photographies
visuellement saint-benoît-du-sault ce
que joe gibbs si toutes ces maisons
anciennes ses toitures moi je fais
beaucoup de photos donc toutes ses
lignes tout
ccc beaucoup si sobre c'est et puis y'a
pas beaucoup de touristes donc c'est
agréable on peut faire nos photos
tranquillement ça a vraiment un cachet
particulier
saint-benoît-du-sault attira bientôt
davantage d'artistes le département et
la communauté de communes ont engagé la
rénovation de la plus vieille bâtisse du
village un prieuré du 7e siècle qui
abritait des moines bénédictins donc il
pourra y avoir effectivement des
résidences d'artistes il pourra y avoir
aussi du numérique il pourra y avoir des
expositions que ce soit de la peinture
il pourra aussi être fait des séminaires
enfin tout tout est à l'étude autre gros
chantier à l'oeuvre la réhabilitation du
portefeuille un étang qui bordent les
remparts de la cité il serait remis en
eau au mois de mars les objectifs c'est
qu'ils reprennent sa vraie vie c'est à
dire qu'il faut que les gens puissent
venir soit se balader autour soit
éventuellement y pêcher comme c'était à
l'accoutumée d'ici quelques mois un
parcours historique sera créée à saint
benoît du sault les touristes pourront
alors découvrir dans notre oeil cette
cité d'art et d'histoire